AVNI SHAH: Thanks to all of
you for being here today.
Especially, I know taking
time out of your weekend
is a big deal.
And I also want to say
thanks for sharing snippets
of your personal story, for
those of you that just got up
a few minutes ago.
I was just sitting
in the back, and it
was pretty inspiring to hear.
So I'm really
excited to be here.
I'm really honored to
be helping kick off
the day with all of you.
I thought I would
just talk a little bit
about my own personal
story, how I ended up
where I am, and
some of the things
that I've learned along the way.
And I guess I'll start off
by making a confession.
I was not one of
those kids that wanted
to study computer science from
the day I came out of the womb.
I actually didn't even
touch a computer probably
until I was 10.
And even then, it
was to play games.
I was playing "Oregon
Trail" or "Lemmings"
or something like that.
I didn't teach myself to
code in my spare time.
I was probably running
around with the neighborhood
kids or something like that.
So I wasn't one
of those kids that
had computer science in their
blood from the early days.
But there was
something that I liked
to do from when I was
young, and that was
to build things with my hands.
It started with
Legos, and then I
graduated to building shelves
or furniture with my dad,
to wiring our media cabinet, to
fixing things around the house.
So I guess I knew
from an early age
that I wanted to be
able to create things.
And, in fact, we took
this test in third grade
that was supposed to
tell us what we were
going to be when we grew up.
And it was one of those tests
that was totally see through,
so you could tell exactly how
the questions and the answers
were going to correlate
to what occupation you
were going to end up with.
And so like any seven-year-old,
I decided to game the system.
And so I picked
the exact answers
that I thought correlated
with building or engineering,
though I might not have
called it that at the time.
And I think my test
results came back,
and it said I should be a
carpenter or a watchmaker.
I might have over-corrected
a little bit.
But I was happy about that,
because the essence was there.
The career that said I should
use my hands to build things.
And I have to
admit this was much
to my parents', in particular
my father's, dismay.
He was, like most
parents of his generation
who had immigrated
from elsewhere
in the world-- India in
his case-- job stability
was really top of mind.
And I mean, I think
it's understandable
from their viewpoint.
My dad is actually an engineer.
My mom's an accountant.
And the economy hadn't
always been nice to them.
So when they looked at me
and what they wanted for me,
they really wanted me to have
an occupation or a career that
was really recession-proof.
And for them, that was medicine.
So my dad really wanted
me to be a doctor.
And honestly, I can't even
use the past tense there
because he will still
call me up and ask me
if I want to take the MCAT
just in case, over the weekend,
because I can just do that.
So if my dad had
had his way, my path
wouldn't have consisted of MIT.
It wouldn't have consisted
studying computer science
and electrical engineering.
It wouldn't have
consisted of Google.
But to be fair, my
third grade rebellion
was not the only reason my
path ended up the way it was.
As I was looking back
and just thinking
through all of the major
moments and, I guess, decisions
that led to where I am
today, I realized that there
was another common thread.
And that was this.
When faced with a decision
where one of the choices
is really uncomfortable
or scary, do that thing.
Because those are
the moments and those
are the times where you actually
learn and grow the most.
And to be fair, I've
done the opposite, too.
So I can compare and contrast.
And, of course, that fear
is not the only reason
to do something.
But it should go in the pros
column and not the cons column.
And that's what I thought I'd
talk a little bit about today.
So the first really difficult
decision I remember making
was where to go to college.
I think at the time
my dad was still
partially convinced I
would come to my senses
and go to med school, at least
stay home close to Alabama.
But I was fortunate enough
to get into MIT, although I
wasn't sure if I wanted to go.
It was really far away.
It was supposed
to be really hard.
And I didn't know if I
could cut it, to be honest.
I was used to being
the top of my class
or near the top of
my class in Alabama,
and I knew that wasn't going to
be the case if I went to MIT.
So I was scared
to make that leap.
And then the more
I thought about it,
the more I realized that I
was going to college to learn.
And if I was going
there to learn,
I might as well surround
myself with people
that I can learn from.
I might as well be a small
fish in a big pond learning
from everyone around me.
And so I went to MIT.
And over the four years,
I learned a whole bunch
of interesting CS-y things.
But I also learned
that I could do it,
that I could cut it there.
And that actually gave
me a lot of confidence
for the next steps in my life.
And the next step in
my life was deciding
what to do after college.
So this was back
in 2003, and it was
after a little
mini economic turn
down, like a little
mini bubble burst.
I remember a lot
of my friends who
had graduated the year
before were given job
offers that were then
rescinded before they even
started their jobs.
So a lot of people
actually across the country
were staying in school because
that was advisable, I guess,
at the time.
And MIT in particular
is pretty research
and academic focused, so
most of the people I knew,
especially CS students, were
staying on to do research,
get their PhDs,
Masters, whatever.
So first of all, the
decision to go into industry
was leaving everything
I knew behind.
Leaving all my friends, leaving
research, leaving academia,
leaving school for the
first time, behind.
And then that was
compounded when I was trying
to decide where to go to work.
So back then, Google was
not the household name
that it is today.
In fact, when I told
my parents about it,
they called it Goofle.
So I was deciding between
that and Microsoft, which
of course was very well known.
And so for them, thinking
again about job stability,
they were like,
absolutely, hands down you
should go to Microsoft.
Absolutely.
And many of the people I talked
to gave me that same advice.
And I guess from that
perspective, it makes sense.
Like, how stable could a
company called Goofle be, right?
Doesn't seem wise.
But I wasn't so convinced.
I wasn't so sure, and I debated
back and forth for three weeks.
I lost so much sleep
just trying to think
about where I should go work.
One day I would be like,
yes, Microsoft, clearly
the right choice.
And then the next day,
I would be like, no.
Maybe I should try it.
Maybe I should do Google.
And I was just really torn.
And in the end,
there was one thing
that I just couldn't let go of.
I remember after my
interviews at Microsoft--
it was a full day of interviews.
I was exhausted like
you would expect.
Interviews are really draining.
So I got back to
the hotel, and I
think I just slept for like 12
hours after those interviews.
But after my interviews at
Google, I was energized.
12 years later, I
can still remember
how I felt after a full day
of interviews at Google.
It was, I don't know.
It was tingly.
I could feel it in my body,
and I couldn't let that go.
I just couldn't let
that feeling go.
And so ultimately, I
decided to come to Google.
And it has been an amazing
11 and 1/2 years since.
I joined when Google
was pretty young,
so I got to see it grow,
go through immense periods
of growth.
I think we have 50 times
the number of employees
now than we did when I joined.
I got to work on a ton
of interesting projects
from Search to Google Toolbar to
Maps to Chrome, where I am now.
I got to work with a
lot of amazing people.
Again, I'm a small
fish in a big pond,
and it's really great
to be able to learn
from everyone around me.
It's also where I met my
husband, so it all worked out,
I guess, in the end.
As a quick side note, actually,
in making that decision
I learned this tactic for how
to make hard decisions that I
thought I would share because
I found it extremely useful.
So what I do is I
try on the decision
before I actually commit.
Kind of like you would try
on a dress or a pair of pants
before you buy them, right?
So what I do is I tell myself
I've made the decision,
but I don't tell anyone else.
I don't actually send any
emails or formally accept,
but I tell myself I've made it.
I sleep as though I made
it, and then I wake up
and I see how I feel.
And if I don't regret it, I know
I've made the right decision.
And I have used that for
many of the tough decisions
I've made since then and
told other people about it,
and it tends to get
positive reviews.
So I thought I would
pass that along.
In fact, I used it
to name my first kid.
I would call my belly
different names every day
until one just stuck
and felt right.
Having a little
less luck this time.
But I am trying
on multiple names,
so I'm still trying
on to see what works.
The next really
difficult decision
came about six years later.
So the summer of 2009,
where I had the opportunity
to go to Zurich, lead a new
project for Google Maps,
and manage a team for
the very first time.
In addition to that, I
had just gotten married,
so I would be
living with somebody
for the first time in my life
in a new country with no friends
or family working at
a job that I was 100%
convinced I was totally
unqualified for.
I was going to be expected to
lead a team I had never met,
work on a product I
had never worked on,
and manage a team of people,
many of whom were older than me
and considerably more
experienced than me.
And I remember being
on our honeymoon,
the last week of our honeymoon
in Bora Bora, of all places.
Just thinking to myself,
like, I can't do it.
This is crazy.
I'm under-qualified.
I have been somehow fooling
people for six years,
and they're going to
finally find me out.
It's over.
The gig is up.
I'm done.
And I thought
about it some more.
And I have to
admit with the help
of a very supportive husband,
I came to realize three things.
First, if I had indeed been
fooling people for six years,
I had done a pretty
damn convincing job.
So maybe I could keep it
up for a couple more years.
But more importantly,
that the feeling
I was having, this
impostor syndrome,
is something that is shared
with people at all levels, men
and women alike.
So I wasn't alone.
It was completely natural
to have that feeling.
Second, that I had a bunch of
people that believed in me.
My husband believed in me.
My manager at the time
and mentor, Marissa Mayer,
believed in me.
My new manager believed in me.
And honestly, if they
all believed in me, maybe
I should believe in
me just a little bit.
And then third, this was
the path I had chosen.
I had chosen product management.
I knew one day I was going
to be in a position where
I was going to end up
managing people if I did well.
So I might as well
try it, right?
And if I fail, I fail.
At least I will have learned
something in the process.
And so I went.
And it turned out to be one
of the best experiences.
I have learned things I couldn't
have even predicted if I tried
to write them down on paper.
I learned that I really
like managing people,
and I'm actually OK at it.
I learned how to come on to a
new team and gain credibility.
I learned about myself, that
when I do come on to a new team
I feel miserable and incompetent
for about six months.
And then magically, it seems
to get better after that point.
I learned about
building products
for users with completely
different perspectives
than the one that I was used to.
And I learned about
being a better coworker.
Being nine time zones away from
Mountain View for two years,
I brought back with
me a lot of empathy
about working with people
in different offices
that has been really
useful ever since.
On a personal level, my husband
and I traveled the world.
We got introduced to new
countries and cultures
and cuisines.
We got to know each
other much better
during our first two
years of marriage
because we were isolated
together with each other.
So it was amazing, and
I almost didn't do it.
I almost let fear
and uncertainty
and insecurity keep me
from what turned out
to be one of the biggest
learning experiences
I've had in the last decade.
So I guess I will end
with another confession.
Doing this talk wasn't
an easy decision for me.
I mean, obviously not
as hard as deciding
to move to another country
for a couple of years.
But it still wasn't easy.
While I've done a decent
amount of public speaking,
I guess I've never gotten up
in front of a bunch of people
and talked about myself or
my experiences or things
like that.
So this was pretty
uncomfortable.
And I remember when
Natalie asked me
if I would be willing to do it.
I immediately
thought, I don't know.
I don't know what I'm going
to say to hundreds of people.
I don't know if I have
an interesting story
or something I can talk about.
And to be honest, oh my
god, it was so much easier
just to say no.
I mean, I have a
good excuse, right?
I'm 6 and 1/2 months pregnant.
I'm tired.
I have migraines.
I have a two-year-old at home.
I have a full-time job.
It was so much easier
to just say no and not
push myself to go that extra bit
and work on this and do this.
And I realize,
though, that this,
this engaging with other
professional women,
getting together and
building a community where
we support and we celebrate each
other, this is important to me.
This is worth--
this is something
that I want to take part in.
And so before I went
to sleep at night,
I told myself I
was going to do it.
I didn't tell Natalie yet.
I told myself I
was going to do it.
I slept on it.
I woke up.
I felt good about it.
I really did that to
make this decision.
And it felt right.
So I emailed her, and I told her
I would do it, and here I am.
And in the process, at least
I've learned a few things.
I've learned a little
bit about myself.
I've gotten some time
to reflect on my path.
I've learned a bit
about taking risks
in the face of fear
and uncertainty.
In fact, especially in the
face of fear and uncertainty
because from my
experience what I've found
is it's those times where you
not only have a steep learning
curve, but you have the step
function learning curve.
It's where you
grow and you thrive
and you flourish the most.
And it makes it worthwhile.
So I hope the next
time any of you
are faced with such a
decision, one of which
feels really
uncomfortable or scary
or pushes you out of
your comfort zone,
I hope you take the
time and the opportunity
to try it on and
ultimately go for it.
Thank you again for
being here today.
[APPLAUSE]